with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller Von Miller
howdy guys welcome to this week's Von
cast this is your host Von Miller I'm
live from Orchard Park in my office and
uh you guys are watching on the bleacher
report app
um first and foremost
I want to say thank you to Bill's Mafia
in the city of Orchard Park in the City
of Buffalo for digging us out and um you
know helping out and making sure me and
all of my teammates
um made it to our game it was pretty
crazy you know we got
77 inches of snow and if you do do quick
math that's about six foot four
um you know I was in Denver and I've
seen snow before and I've and I've been
in snow but six and a half feet of snow
is just ridiculous and the only way that
we could have made it out was you know a
huge team effort and you know huge
effort from the community um lucky for
me
I live right next door to coach
McDermott so I just called coach
McDermott the night before and I said
hey
whatever you doing tomorrow I'm with you
and he's like hey I'm gonna give you uh
I I hit you up in the morning and I'll
let you know when I'm ready to go
and I just knew I was cool man honestly
when I moved here to Orchard Park I kind
of felt like that was kind of like my
insurance policy I didn't think that
I would ever get snowed in or anything
like that but I knew if it were to snow
if I ever needed a ride to work or
anything like that then you know I live
right next door to coach McDermott and
um the snow was crazy it just it just
Lake Erie just dumped on us snow after
snow after snow for a whole 24 hours and
at first I was kind of skeptical at
first I was kind of you know thinking
like man it might not snow like that it
might you know they might just do a
little something but
huge snowflakes non-stop 24 hours man it
was it was crazy man looking for me my
son was here I live right next door to
coach McDermott we had plenty of food
um but that wasn't the case for
everybody so I just want to say thank
you to Orchard Park thank you to Bill's
Mafia you guys are incredible we had to
reschedule our game and some people were
saying that some people were saying that
the NFL has gotten solved they should
have made us play in the snow and I'm
like hey I don't have a problem playing
in the snow but what about the safety
concerns of fans getting to and from the
stadium
you know um people driving in the snow
to and from that's all I was concerned
about I wasn't really concerned about
playing in the snow I mean football is
just one of those things where you just
you just tough it out but it was just so
crazy man so we had to you know pack up
and really send our stuff to Detroit
this is I'm playing in Detroit two weeks
straight played in Detroit on Sunday and
we got a Thursday night game on Detroit
been a crazy couple of days but without
any further Ado let me get to this
week's guess this is this is this is one
of my guys man this this is one of my
guys I've been knowing my guy for a long
time fellow Tech Zane and Maggie
um fellow first team All-American at
Texas A M
um um he holds the record for most
receiving yards in a single game
and in a season
he's a Super Bowl champion he's a
four-time pro bowler
he is the books all-time leader in
touchdowns and yards from scrimmage
and I think you you guys can can figure
it out now it's my boy Mike Evans
Mike what's good my boy
chilling on the off day thanks for
having me bro man for sure man I I I as
you probably heard man we got 77 inches
of snow and you're in Tampa I'm looking
in the back the weather's nice
you just coming off a Bobby what did you
do for your ball week just went back to
Galveston you know the hometown chill
with the fam
did a couple community events
that's pretty much it man watch some
football
so it's a good week did you get a chance
to play some golf no golf no golf
no golf man I've been playing golf for
two years and I know we had that Texas A
M we had the Texas A M alumni uh golf
tournament and I saw you kind of get the
bug and like you know that was that was
dope to see man because I was in that
same spot just a year before man you get
out there with your boys and you start
hitting the clubs and hitting the balls
and then that that competitive nature
just sets in like no I'm no I'm gonna
figure this out bro I'm gonna figure it
out it can't be that hard man I'm gonna
figure it out and you can drink and play
golf so that's pretty cool too right you
can drink play golf you're out there
four hours with your boys it's really
not nothing it's really nothing like it
man I really just enjoy being outside I
enjoy um the companionship with my boys
and you know my family and it just gives
you another thing to have in common with
your teammates
um it's just another thing that me and
my dad and me and my brothers can do and
this is a game that we can play for the
rest of our lives you know I started
when I was 33 and the seniors you can
qualify for the senior tour at 50. so
that gives me 17 years to become a pro
how old are you right now I'm 33 33.
okay 30 I'm 33 years old so it gives me
17 years to get ready for the senior
tour and um you know deep down on that
football field but I'm still trying man
I'm still trying young man like a young
man out there I think the key is once
she starts saying I'm old and once once
like the everyday like
um the everyday grind of football and
the things you do once that once she
starts telling yourself like man I'm
getting tired of this so man I'm getting
old I think that's when you really
become old because your body is going to
do what it's gonna do you really have no
control over your body but your body is
going to listen to your mind too and
once you start becoming old once your
mindset becomes old like it's just down
here from there I mean you see Tom Brady
do it man like
you see him you see him doing all the
time he's not old mentally bro like the
body gonna do what it's gonna do but
once you become old mentally it's not
you can't bounce back from that that's
facts I agree with that speaking of oh
or or time you haven't been playing Rob
receiver for a long time you played wide
receiver your senior year senior high
school but look people always think that
but I have I played when I was younger I
just stopped playing when I got to high
school because I wanted to focus on
basketball
and um I've always loved the game of
football it's just you know when I got
to high school I got a little taller
basketball is my favorite sport I just
wanted to focus on that uh my senior
year I just didn't want to be bored in
in school and my friends knew I could
play so they were like senior year you
got to come out and play
um I went out and played and it was one
of the best decisions I ever made man
for sure man continuing to kill stuff
and I know we're talking about killing
stuff man you chasing history right now
man you 329 yards away from a thousand
yards which would be your ninth
consecutive season doing that that would
break your own record of eight seasons
you knew that I'm of course you know
that man of course you know that man
yeah did you know did you did you know
you're 28 yards away from 10 000 yards
10 000 career yards yeah I do that too
there's some reason I'm not aware of but
those workers are I'm aware of because
you know that's a that's a pretty cool
feat and hopefully I can get it you know
one catch that'll be cool I wanted to do
it at home yeah at home this weekend
coming up brother did you know you're 88
yards away from passing Shannon Sharp
for the 50 for 50th all time and career
receiving yard
Uncle SEI yeah Uncle Shay Shay man you
88 yards away
shout out Uncle Shannon I got to catch
her how do you be so consistent man like
what like talk to me about like being
consistent I know I know I know I wanna
I Wanna Get It from like Mike Evans you
know I don't play offense yeah I want to
see how like yeah what is your mindset
what how do you what is the what is the
not necessarily secret but how do you do
it bro
I mean it's a lot of things combined you
know um I've been blessed with this
ability and this size and uh this is
competitive because I love the game of
football and you got to have guys
believe in you
so quarterbacks have to believe in you
the offensive coordinator and um you
gotta take care of your body I feel like
each year throughout my career I've
learned how to take care of my body
better and better so that's been a plus
for me and um you know just practice you
know how it is the game slows down each
year and um you know that's just what's
been happening you know it's been
blessed to be in this position so I'm
gonna take full advantage of it and have
fun as long as possible you know you
know give them all that's dope to hear
bro because you know people ask me all
the time like bun like when you go like
when you're gonna hang it up when you're
gonna do I'm like bro I it was days and
and it was nice that I
that I got on my hands and knees at the
end of my bed and I prayed like Lord
please let me go out here and have a
good game
uh let me get a scholarship let me ball
out in this bowl game I hope I get
drafted like these are talks that I had
with God right and you know look back on
it 12 years in
like I just don't want to like give that
gift away I wanna I don't even want to
say use it all up but I want it for food
I really want to take full advantage of
the talent and the gift that God gave me
and I just want to keep going until he
says I can't go like I didn't play 12
years I want two Super Bowls like it's
easy to like get complacent you know as
you know but for me I'm I'm just not I'm
just not satisfied bro I just it's I
just want to keep going as long as I
possibly can go and it's not for anybody
else it's for me you know when you start
having kids and stuff you like you want
them to be able to look at you and what
you do in your career and you want them
to like lean on like some of the things
that you did and I want to be able to
tell them like man I I left it all out
there and I did everything that I
possibly could do to um provide for you
guys and to take full advantage of the
gift that God gave me because it's a lot
of people that I played with that was
better than me faster than me stronger
than me all of these things but they're
not here right now and I am and I want
to take full advantage of of this
opportunity man and when you get to like
year 12 I'm sure you do the same thing
you start thinking about Legacy and like
what do you want your legacy to be and
for me I just want to win as many
championships as I possibly can
um I really don't care what people think
about me
um as far as like the outside world but
I do care about what my teammates think
about me and the people that they really
know me I care about what they say about
me when I'm not in the room and those
are two things that I care about I want
to win as much as I can I only get as
many sacks as I possibly can
um and I care about what my teammates
the guys that I spend most of my time
with
um you know 80 of my time with I care
about what they say about me man and
what what do you uh what do you want
your Legacy Legacy to be I know you
think about it man like you have an idea
or what do you want your legacy to be I
couldn't have put it any better like
what you just said is like you know what
what I think all the time and how I feel
about being in this situation
um but that's why you know you're great
you know the greats have that type of
mindset they want to keep going as long
as they can they don't want to you know
give that gift away like you said so you
know I feel the same way bro like God
blessed me with this talent and this to
be in this position so I'm just taking
full advantage and keep having fun while
I do it because you know you get down
you know there's there's times you get
embarrassed out here and and things like
that you get injured but it's like we
dream to be in this position for so long
like I'm not gonna let a couple plays
here and there like the tear my
confidence and you know my legacy and
you know how I feel about the game so I
just try to be as positive I can
as much as possible
for sure man you know coaches always say
not only coaches but you know people
that really observe the game and you
know the the um the players that have
come before me man they tell you like
playing in the NFL is only a short piece
of your life like so while I'm here in
this in this in this short moment of my
life you know this whatever 20 22 years
or however long I play I want to take
full advantage of that like I want to go
for 20. I'm going for 20 you know I'm
aiming High I'm going I'm going for 20
Bruce Smith he played for 19 years and
he had two awesome sack leader all-time
sack leader at 200 he played 19 years so
in my head like if I can play 20 years
and I can average 10 cents in Buffalo
that's pretty cool yeah he played him he
played in Buffalo man he's coming to my
bet my password Summit he's one of the
biggest reasons why I came here
um you know I talked to him and he was
like hey you it's gonna be in you're
gonna be in the cold like offensive line
but they're not gonna want to get out
their stands you're gonna be able to get
a jump on on the ball Josh Allen they're
gonna score points you know all of these
things man and I that was my that's that
I would say that like that's my OG or my
vet and you have a vet too you have an
OG too that's that's throwing you the
ball every day man Tom Brady man I'm
such a huge fan of Tom Brady and uh what
he's done on and off the football field
man and I actually think that the NFL is
better when Tom Brady wins like when he
when he wins like I think it is when I'm
on his team for sure yeah Michelle
Michelle man the atmosphere is just the
atmosphere around the NFL is just it's
just great man so I know y'all been
struggling yeah I've been struggling you
know to start the season but you know
he's turning around bro he's still he's
still Tom Brady man and I'm a huge fan
of Tom Brady I'm a huge fan of you man
how has he changed the way that you that
you play or that you prepare for games
oh this he's he's so detailed he's the
most detailed player I've ever played
with so he makes sure that we're all on
point and ready so since I've been
playing with him my mental errors have
been way lower you know obviously you
know everybody still makes mistakes but
like our team as a whole like our mental
errors go way down and that's going to
be you know cause for more success on
your team uh when guys are doing the
right things in the right spots
especially with the talents we have so
you know I'm just
I'm just more detailed going into the
game and knowing the assignments and the
coverages and things like that
and taking care of my body is the main
thing I've learned you know the last
three years been playing with him he's
always getting treatment throughout the
day always bro it's a 24-hour thing like
it's you have to always there is no when
you're performing when you're a
professional athlete there is no down
time or no chill time so I spend more
time trying to get my body ready to go
or doing it could be as simple as as
Norma Tech or ice tub I spend most of my
day like doing that stuff not
necessarily practicing or in a in the
film room or anything like that I spend
most of my time just getting ready to
play in another football game you put
the time in you'll get the results
yeah for sure I got I got so many Tom
Brady stories man and I've been in the
league 12 years I've been around Tom
um I started to really love Tom when I
got to kick it with him outside of like
on the football field I was in the
Kentucky I went to the Kentucky Derby
and they had me as a color commentator a
lifestyle correspondent at the Kentucky
Derby NBC and they were telling me like
hey could I get an interview with Tom
like could I interview Tom and I was
like man y'all just y'all just let them
chill man y'all just let them chill and
it's like he never does any interview
man if you can do that man it'd be great
I'm like man like I know I got no time
man I'm gonna go over there and I'm
gonna ask him man now ask him
and he was like yeah sure let's do it
and everybody from NBC just like lit up
they was like
bro is he he's bro he's gonna he and it
was like live and it was like right here
right now and like of course you know we
had a couple of drinks man it was like
this it was like this dope moment on
National Television at the Kentucky
Derby we had our hats on and he wasn't
like I was asking him questions he was
giving them back it wasn't like me
putting the mic up to him and like just
one-sided bro like he was into it I was
into it man and you know he didn't have
to do that and we he did it for free man
he had to do none of that man and I
kicked it with him after
um it was him and Julian Edelman I think
Garoppolo and all the guys I went out I
went out to like a couple of parties
with those guys man I'm like bro like
Tom kick it like how I kick it I like
bro like I did I like dude I was like
they kicking hard kick it man and you
know I had got his number and I had did
the pass for Summit later and I had did
like a virtual password Summit and um he
was going to be like a guest on the
password Summit like a quarterback like
uh correspondent it's supposed to be
like a surprise because I had like 5 000
people like virtual for the past first
summit I suppose a surprise I'm with Tom
Brady
um the schedules didn't work out but I
still got a chance to talk to Tom Brady
after by the past first summit
um I asked him for a jersey and I didn't
have to ask him five or six times I
asked him for a jersey one time
boom them up was there like in in two
two three days bro like I didn't have to
remind them none of that none of that
stuff bro and you know I ran into him
like uh at the at UCLA after he got done
throwing bro and it just I just come to
the conclusion like
anybody that doesn't like Tom Brady they
just simply don't like winning bro and
that's that's not a good reason to not
like somebody because they win and
they're not successful bro do you have
like a good Tom Brady story that you
could tell us that you want to tell us I
got I got so many great ones
um he's such a down-to-earth guy like
like you said like growing up I didn't
like him when I was a kid because I was
a Peyton Manning fan most people know
that by now but uh you know when you're
a kid you're a little naive you don't
really understand but you know what I
definitely when I went to high school
and college you know I definitely
respected his greatness but when I met
him he was such a down-to-earth guy he
loves his kids he's a great father and
um I have a lot of great stories with
him you know I've been with him for the
past three years
um
one cool thing we did we went to the
right after Kobe when everything was uh
starting to open back up the UFC had an
event in Jacksonville and uh Usman and
mastered all fight fought for the second
time and Tom hooked it up he got us
backstage to meet Dana White the
president uh we met a lot of a lot of
people back there and I'm a huge fight
fan so to be that close and personal and
he just he hooked it up like it was
nothing we had a great time
and uh you know that's it obviously the
Super Bowl Parade was
was lit I mean you know everybody's
having a great time hopefully we do that
again I know y'all trying to have y'all
on Parade but we finna get hot I feel
like I don't know man I mean I
I want y'all to have a lot of success
man and win a lot of games it's just
just one game if you know if we if we if
we play y'all man you know I gotta I
gotta get one too man what was you know
you say you know Tom Brady is it's such
a down to earth guy man what was his
reaction when you gave his 600th career
touchdown ball to a fan well during the
game he came up to me
well he was like good catch and all that
and I said I apologize do you want me to
get the ball back for you and then he
was like nah you're good babe and then
you know luckily Our God Tim jaraki got
it back for us but um he handled it cool
yeah they're cool I didn't know it was
his you know to my defense I didn't know
I'm just you just don't even happening
yeah you just touched down and it was
something I've done before Tom came to
our team so I just used to get a ball to
the fans and it stands if I scored touch
but uh
of course he did man that's that's Tom
Brady man he's a cool quarterback man
speaking of cool quarterback except
Rocky right there
oh the other guy right there
that guy's name is uh Byron
for sure you know Tom is a cool
quarterback man speaking of cool
quarterbacks man you played with another
one of my favorite quarterbacks man
Johnny Manziel man he the man I love
Johnny man I love Johnny man that's my
God man
um how did I didn't get the I didn't get
a chance to play it with with Johnny man
all of my time I wish I had my time with
you man that would have been so bruh me
and me man Johnny man it just would have
been crazy man like man I was in the
league and just College Station just
changed when Johnny got there like it
just it just totally changed like he
brought like such a different light upon
College Station and Texas A M and I
think still to this day they they still
are like living from the light and
exposure that Johnny put on that on our
franchise man like he he definitely
touched our franchise and he only played
there two years right
he only played two four seasons and he
was a red shirt before
yeah he wasn't he wasn't even there that
long man and I didn't get I didn't get
to play or be a teammate with Johnny
um you know the Aggie Network is just so
strong man and I got to kick it with
Johnny off the football field and I got
the you know know him as a person man
and that's like that's my God man talk
about some of the you know talk about
your time playing with him at Texas A M
y'all want a lot of big games beat
Alabama
like how was how was playing with Johnny
man at Texas A M he was unbelievable
well right away you know we red shirted
in 2011 we came in together and just
right away I knew it was he was
different
because he could he was a freak athlete
you know he could hoop play baseball and
he could make all the throws on the run
and in the pocket you know he's a little
smaller quarterback but you know he used
to give our defense fits our first team
defense me and him will be on Scout team
they'd make Johnny Manziel go live and
he'd just be all over the field just
making plays and
he just was different and he made it
look so easy out there
he just was always confident going into
every game and it was just fun to you
know play with him for those two years
and you know change the culture down
there in Aggieland
so the biggest game that I played in I
would say I played in three three games
that were huge man uh my senior year
Nebraska beat we beat Nebraska six I
think we beat them six to three or nine
to six or something like that no no
touchdowns were scored it was national
televisionally televised game they were
ranked I think they were top 10 or
something like that we beat them
OU at home
we we beat those guys too um that was a
huge game for us we're supposed to lose
that game by so much had had some goal
line stops and of course whenever you
can beat Texas beat Texas my senior year
like that was that was a huge one too
man what were some of the biggest gray
had a big game he had a huge hit I think
he went for 200 yards man
what's like your top three games as an
Aggie of course that that Alabama game
would be one Bama when we beat him
obviously he was was number one even
though I didn't have a good game you
know although the second half of my red
shirt freshman year 2012 which was our
best team
um I was hurt like I had a strained
hamstring and I was just playing through
it I couldn't really run go Ross I was
just running stop routes and Slants and
stuff like that and big body and you
know back shoulder Fades but it was
working I don't know how I was able to
do that but you know that game the
Alabama game was number one in 2012 we
beat them
um
latex we played latex uh short-handed we
were winning 34-7 I think at halftime
and they came all the way back they were
ranked like 23rd and we were top 20 as
well and they came all the way back and
tied the game up at the end and then
Johnny like had one of his best games I
think he had like close to 200 rushing
yards 300 passing yards
you know I had a couple big plays that
game so that was definitely one of them
and when we beat Oklahoma in the Cotton
Bowl
that was that was fun that was a really
fun game at T Stadium Cowboy stadium man
that was a huge man I I check in on the
Aggies man and I watch the Aggies man
and you know we had the best
recruiting class in the history of
college football last year with 13
five-star recruits we got Jimbo Fisher
we got the best facilities in the world
I know it's not a recruiting pitch for
anybody that's that's that's listening
I'm just saying like bro we have the
best of the best man and you know we got
a video of a a half empty Stadium
from this last place we have you have
you seen that video
I hadn't but I heard about it
um our games never like that no matter
what
like
Aggie fans don't do that okay I see it
man I have never seen this thing like
that who we play UMass I think it might
be a combination of I think it might be
a combination of you know how we've been
playing this year the weather the
weather was bad and the team that we
were playing I think it was just a
combination of everything but like you
said bro I've never seen this game is
that that's not even a spring game like
no spring games don't even look like
that
what do we need to do to get our team
back on track it starts with the
quarterback position
always I feel like I mean we got to get
find the right guy quarterback
um got to build trust around them gotta
establish a good running game I mean we
got The Talented the talent to to
compete
I I really don't know like I haven't
been around as much so I don't I don't
know
man
you don't think quarterback number one
we have to find the right guy
quarterback
you know like you might not notice about
me but when I'm when I'm done playing
football like one of my dreams is to be
a gym I've been around some great ones
so I kind of look at the football and
college football from a different lens
and you know I like I like our
quarterbacks I like our quarterbacks all
the quarterbacks that have been the guys
in high school that were ranked in high
school I think
I don't think it's coach Fisher you know
that's not I think in college you always
you get to a point where it's hard to
find coaching like yeah you can't do
that every time not it ain't Jimbo's
fault you really just got to watch this
season away and next year we have to
come with it these 13 five stars that we
had they'll be sophomores next year and
now if we don't have success next year
then you now you got to start pointing
your finger and in college a little bit
more but we definitely got to give them
time we got a really young team
and football's hard as hell especially
if you want to see that's like the
second size level in the world
bro it's tough but you know how the
Aggies they they gotta we gotta win and
we gotta win now especially after you
know 13 five stars that we've got a lot
of money is a lot of money is going into
the you know the football team so
all of these facilities and everything
that we got man but you know I I think
we got the talent I think we'd be able
to turn it around and you know the GM in
me the GM in me right looking at these
college players and looking forward to
what I want to do now I got a game that
I want to play with you it's called the
cheat code
we've already established like your
cheat code you know I've seen you play
I've seen your game and stuff too I
don't know if you're hacking you're
probably hacking in real life too
because you code in real life are you
code on the game I'm gonna show you four
offensive lineups and you can tell me
which one is breaking the most scoring
records
and um you know I got you and all of
them of course I just want to see what
lineups do you think I want to sharpen
my genome skills and I'm always a fan of
iron sharpens iron you know you're
you're iron I'm iron I just want to see
I just want to see if I'm if I'm right
man let's let's see Optimus number one
office number one is Lamar Jackson
Mike Evans
Travis Kelsey Derrick Henry and David
bakhtiari Lamar Jackson is one of the
most electrified players you know in
history of football Derrick Henry is one
of the best running backs in the history
of football Travis Kelsey one of the
best tight ends in history and Dave is a
unbelievable left tackle he's probably
one of the best two in history so I mean
this is going to be it's gonna be too
hard to choose everybody's going to be
great
number one
I think this offense would be more run
oriented and I think the dynamic that
Lamar Jackson and Travis Kelsey will
have will kind of be like Patrick
Mahomes and Travis Kelsey you know Lamar
is going to be running all over the
place
he likes Andrew he's gonna hit you he's
going to hit Travis Kelsey you know I
think this is going to be more of a
running type of offense of course we got
Dave David back we got bhaktiari up top
he's going to be able to block it up for
the passes up the field
um I I like that I like that lineup but
here's here's office number two we got
Josh Allen Mike Evans Justin Jefferson
Trent Williams and Lane Johnson
what do you like about this line
two receivers we're gonna throw the ball
a lot
like you said offensive One's Gonna Be
run heavy
offense two Josh likes to sling The Rock
me Jay Jets
big Trent one of the best old Tigers all
time big Lane as well
I mean I love offense number two a lot
of targets
number two
offens number two is gonna pass the [ __ ]
out the ball I'll tell you that right
now you got one of the best the best
left tackle in the league and you got
the best right tackle in the league and
of course you know one and two they can
go back and forth you know but you got
two of the best offensive line in the
league two of the best wide receivers in
the league number one and number two and
if it's not number one number two is two
and one like you know how this goes up
and down each and every week and then we
got the best quarterback I know USA
differently but you know you got Tom
Brady I know but he's definitely Josh is
definitely one of them though Josh Allen
I like I really like offense number two
I like offense number two a little bit
better than like office number one and
it's not as a indictment on anybody and
there's no running back in this one yeah
it's not an indictment on anybody I'm
just you know we just playing the game
right here and this is offense number
three right
so let me show you office number three
we got
Patrick Mahomes Mike Evans AJ Brown
Quentin Nelson and sequan Barkley what
do you like about that one
I love pepper homes like I'm a huge Pat
Mahomes fan
uh AJ Brown is doing his thing
Quinn Nelson is a beast and saquon's a
beast and he needs to get paid
um I love this offense too
pretty close right now all these
officers are really close right now
it's gonna be a little bit more it's
gonna be dynamic too me and AJ we're
really physical receivers so that's like
two really physical receivers out there
with Quentin Nelson is one of the most
physical guards in the league and saquon
and packing to make plays out of the
pocket in the pocket he could throw it
off his back foot 70 yards
just think about it's a scary offense
right there just think about this whole
offense coach by Andy Reid in Kansas
City like that would be crazy with
drawing up we're going crazy there too
no no we're not throwing coaches we're
not throwing coaches I'm just I'm just
imagining I'm just imagining like no
that's saquan with Andy Reed and Patrick
Mahomes and then you and AJ Brown and
Quinn Nelson blocking the front like
this should be scary too
and this is my last one right here
this is my last one right here offense
number four we got Kirk Cousins
Mike Evans Tyreek Hill
George Kittle and Nick chew
sheesh you like that
against us our team in 2015. that was us
the Buccaneers we was beating them like
by three scores I think and they came
back and beat us damn so you know shout
out Kirkman he's he's always had swag
he's a really smart quarterback good
good ball placement he's very underrated
I like Kirk a lot cheetah man he's doing
his thing no matter who who the
quarterback is the system doesn't matter
he's one of the best players one of the
best weapons in NFL history
man he's doing his thing fastest player
I've ever seen with my own two eyes but
he's so fast so good
George Kittle
pass game Run game he could do it all
Nick Chubb is the one of the toughest
runners in the league we played him next
week
and y'all just played him I mean
all these offenses are scary I don't
know
which one I got to see them all again
but that crazy man I love Nick Chubb I
love George Kittle Tyree kill That's My
Boy Kirk Cousins I was trying to get him
to come to the Denver Broncos when he
was getting ready to leave the
commanders
um and I love Mike Evans of course but
which I'm gonna run through him one more
time and you tell me which one let's go
back to office number one
I'll go back to office number one guy
one was Lamar Jackson Lamar Jackson
Lamar Jackson Travis Kelsey Derrick
Henry about the Ari
offense number two we got Josh Allen
Mike Evans Justin Jefferson Trent
Williams Lane Johnson
um offense number three
we got Patrick Mahomes Mike Evans AJ
Brown Quentin Nelson Shaquan Barkley I
love all these guys by the way like this
is not an indictment on anybody yeah I
love them all as well and then number
four we got Kirk Cousins Mike Evans
Tyree Hill George Kittle and Nick Chubb
I'll go first
me I've seen it from me seeing it from a
pastor's point of view
me seeing it from the type of headaches
that it would give on everybody
I got to go with offense number two
I gotta go with office number two
um Josh Allen uh of course Trent
Williams and Lane Johnson on the same
team oh my God and you got Mike Evans
and Justin Jefferson who
and then you got Josh Allen like what I
mean what people will lose sleep over
this offense people would lose sleep
mode off this offense for sure
which one you got man if you had to pick
one which one would you pick
it's a close call I'm gonna go office
number three
is that is that Pat me AJ you AJ yeah
yeah it's not an indictment or it's not
an indictment or nobody I love them all
but all of these players are Hall of
Fame players man
I don't know it was it was that's close
I really want to pick them all but
because Pat's from Texas yeah and uh
Lopez AJ Brown sec
a little say corn and Clinton Nelson so
I go to yeah they say offense number
three is getting a lot of love in the
chat
um I love man I love patching my homes
like I love Tom Brady too I love Tom
Brady I love Patrick Mahomes
um you know the crazy thing is
I almost got a Tom Brady tattoo and a
Peyton Manning tattoo those are my two
favorite quarterbacks ever and I was it
wasn't gonna say Tom Brady of course or
like hey you like both
or when you got to the league because
I've been a Brady fan I mean one or the
other you know I've been a Brady fan
forever but I played with Peyton Manning
so I got to see that's when it happened
okay I got to see Peyton Manning like up
close and personal and I got to see what
made him great I got the experience and
witness greatness like up close like he
has such he had the way he went about
his business and the things that he did
with his teammates and the way he the
way he led it had such a huge impact on
me and my career and how I lead today
and how I and how I interact with my
teammates so
I love Tom Brady but I I witnessed
Peyton Manning so I was gonna get like
the Peyton Manning 18 and Broncos fun I
was just gonna get the Broncos fund 18
then I was going to get the Patriots
like font like 12 on my ankle but last
minute I decided to change it you know
tattoos hurt so I was like man I'm gonna
just figure another spot I'll be
figuring another space for this I'm glad
I did man but I love these guys though
man I really do man I got somebody in
the chat they asking me about Harry
Potter my favorite what you like about
Harry Potter I I grew up on Harry Potter
man second grade my teacher Mrs Jones
read us the book and then that same year
the first movie came out Sorcerer's
Stone and I went to see her and I fell
in love with the movies I love
everything about it
I love everything about it you know
Harry's the chosen one from birth like I
don't know if you know much about it but
all the odds are stacked against Harry
like he lives with his human aunt and
Uncle and Cousin they do them dirty
you know he's an orphan and he he's just
a chosen one and like the friendship's
in it the way that they all grew
together
uh if you haven't seen the Harry
Potter's I suggest you watch them
especially like you've got young
children
yeah of course man you got a Harry
Potter tattoo
oh yeah I just got a little more I got
the Hogwarts Castle behind that uh
during the bye week so that's one thing
I did in about week
added a little more if we had to choose
a house for you whether what is it
Hufflepuff
uh Slytherin or Gryffindor which one
would you be
it said right there Gryffindor is it
Gryffindor
Mike Evans is totally a Gryffindor
Harry's Gryffindor Ron Hermione
so all my favorite characters I got some
other guys in the NFL let's put them in
in Hogwarts houses
what you think about Tom Brady
what house would he be in Slytherin
slithering
what about what about my guy Jalen
Ramsey
Slytherin Slytherin
we got Aaron Rodgers slytherins are
they're talented you know but they're
like yeah they're a little they're a
little more like you know Savage yeah
all the other houses yeah I know I know
a little bit about uh I know a little
bit about Harry Potter man you know I'd
probably be Slytherin as well I'd
probably be I'd probably be I'd probably
be slithering as well too man
um that's just me I
you know I'm you gotta have that edge
man you gotta had an edge to rush the
pastor man is and you know you can make
alliances and be cool and you know get
stuff done at the end of the day but you
just gotta you just gotta have that that
dog in you man and I got some more guys
on here what you think about Aaron
Rodgers let me see he's like a Cedric
Diggory type so Hufflepuff
Hufflepuff
Rob Gronkowski
well gronk's going to Gryffindor with me
he's Gryffindor he's Gryffindor
uh the Kelsey Brothers
we're gonna put them in uh Gryffindor
Gryffindor Sue Jameis Winston
Ravenclaw
Raven Arabic
Curry cousins
Hufflepuff Hufflepuff for sure yeah
Russell Wilson
Ravenclaw
Ravenclaw
Justin Jefferson
just lived in a Gryffindor I go
Slytherin
and I got I got one more
uh Marshawn Lattimore
I knew that was coming when you said I
got one more you start smoking
[Music]
you know I'm I'm a um you know I don't
want to hold you too long man I got I
got one more
I got one more little segment I want to
do with you man you know I know you want
to celebrate otherwise receivers too you
know everybody loves Mike Evans man and
you know we're in a day and age where
you know people don't get their flowers
and people don't share love and like all
you know that's what that's honestly why
I had to pass for a summit I wanted to
like spread the love to like younger
players that don't get the experience
like the
um Pro Bowl and they don't get to do
some of the things that these other guys
do even though that they're like
successful and they and they Rush their
ass off and they're like great players
they don't get to go to the past they
don't get to go to the the um the Pro
Bowl so I wanted to have a Passover
Summit where we talk about pass rush on
and off the football field and we we can
just hang and I can it's a place where I
can like talk to these guys and tell
them like it's not a coaching clinic by
any means like I learned something from
these guys but it's a place for me where
I can like you know show love to these
guys and tell them like hey bro like
just keep doing this and you're gonna be
this and that like I remember um when
Max Crosby went bro I told I said max
like you're such a great player bro like
this was like way this is like way
before like
you know of course he was going to have
success regardless bro but but I was
like Max like bro like you got
everything that you need bro like you're
gonna be a superstar in this league one
day bro like I'm such a huge fan of you
bro and you know to fast forward to like
I think it was three past four Summers
after that and he had the Florida talk
and he was like Von like when you told
me like hey like I'm gonna be a
superstar one day he was like bro like
that's when I like saw it and felt it
man and for me like that's why I wanted
to have to pass for a summer to like
show love and like create those type of
moments man and if it was other
receivers that you wanted to celebrate
man you know it's a lot of young
receivers out here man making impacts
you know who would be like your top five
current wide receivers other than Mike
Evans
Oh I thought she's about to ask me like
underrated wide receivers underrated
they could be underrated
I hate doing that top five because it's
so hard but do the top five do the top
five
I'll do topography right now I do top
five current right now and then he said
not not include myself
we'll go uh Devonte Adams
Diggs
J Jets
Tyree Hill
is it more Chase
Jamal Chase for sure what about the top
five underrated
wide receivers Scary Terry Terry McLaren
is is the most underrated receiver in
the league I think he's so tough
um
Chris Godwin is super underrated
he's a beast
it's hard there's so many guys that are
underrated in the league
um
let's go Gabe Davis
physical
High Point the ball contest the catch
run out the catch
um of course we got
is Mike Williams underrated
I feel like people talk about Mike
Williams a lot though
I think outside of the football World
outside of the football World they
probably don't talk about as much yeah
we know I know about myself
he has an injury he has an ankle injury
right now but
man he's he's just rocks are getting
better every year he's one of the best
contested catch guys High Point guys in
the league if not the best High Point
guy
um
who else we got so many other guys
Justin Watson Kansas City Chiefs my
former teammate he's number 84. he's
super underrated
he's having a great season this year
called some touchdowns this year man
he's having his best year for his career
that's dope my boy um you know I I want
to let you go but in the chat it's just
I got two questions for you my boy um
what's your favorite team to play
against
and this is from this is from go
underscore 44. I say the same every time
a team that's playing heavy You Know
cover one this man coverage with the
safety like not tilted towards my side
so I love teams that do that and it's
rare to get a team like that it's rare
to get teams like that
uh since like 2015 but um you know teams
that play me like that you know I love
that so cover one teams that play a lot
of man
I like playing against Tom Brady because
no no it's not even about scrambling
it's just like he not really worried
about like let me load up this side and
Chip Von all game like let me motion is
tight end in and crack him like he don't
do none of this stuff
we try we try to and the playoffs came
last year it's just you A.D
Floyd I was all over the place it's just
so it's just so many man um
I felt like I felt like whenever I do
play Tom like he don't really like focus
on me like that he's so focused on his
game and trying to be the best
quarterback that he can be and I kind of
just can I can just play and that's what
all the greats you know that's what all
the greats I don't know Aaron Rodgers
they was chipping me a little bit too
like Aaron Aaron Rodgers you should be
getting chipped um you should be getting
chipped by the way a lot like that's
smart football like who's not gonna you
got to get some chips a lot of people
playing football man I just want a lot
of people play football man but um the
quarterback and this sacred sacks like
or something like you you gotta like
you're one of the best Edge rushers in
history bro you got to get tipped bro
you say you like going against cover one
I like going I like going against the
grace hopefully hopefully we play y'all
in the Super Bowl and we I hope bro we
try to gameplay against you you know
that right we try to chip you with Tommy
quarterback no matter who it is
I got one more question man I will let
you go man I appreciate you bro what
what is the worst weather that you've
ever played in this is from Asia Brown
yeah we play Baltimore
in 2018 I think it was Lamar Jackson's
rookie year I mean it was like 30
degrees but it was pouring down raining
and it was it was a snow year the ball
felt like a brick now it wasn't snow was
just rain ever I think both teams
combined had like 15 20 drops in one
game
I'll say I'll say like 10 to 15 but
the ball was like a brick it was super
slick
tough game and Lamar Jackson went off on
us too that game by the way he's a
rookie making real good plays in the
rain and cold
just crumbling my boy
um you know a case did said I I knew I
love Mike Evans
but he loves Harry Potter and he's now
my favorite receiver of all time that's
Casey that's K sticks that's love this
is my guy Mike Evans man hey my Aggie
brother man my my brother in real life
man I appreciate you taking time out of
your day
um I know the family's well you got a
beautiful family uh bro I just want to
send blessings to all of y'all man
um it's an honor and a privilege to do
this Von cast with you and to talk to
you on on your off day man it's all love
and respect if you ever need me for
anything man if you just want me to come
uh to when when your daughter grows up
and you want me to come dance at the
wedding man you know I Come Dance at the
wedding man whatever you want me to do
man I'm I'm forever in debt to you my
boy hey I love you man and I appreciate
you man and I wish you the very best and
we'll see you in the Super Bowl my boy
I like the sound of that man I
appreciate you being bro thanks for
having me and I still remember you you
throwing up at 5 45 workouts during the
NFL lockout my freshman year I was cool
man he was out there getting it bro I
was trying to come I was trying to come
and steal like because that it ain't it
ain't nothing like working out in
college bro you know like you know you
don't really work out like that beat
them workouts oh man I was trying to
come back and you know work out with
Tony and Cyrus and you know still be a
part of like Texas A M but and boys just
getting it I ain't ran like that since
then
foreign
yes sir my success bro
in conclusion of
this week's Von Cavs
um
we got uh some questions for me it says
Hey GM Von any update on obj
um
obj he's he's going he's going around
he's doing what he he's doing what he do
man he's uh
it's like he's getting recruited again
like you know you got to show love like
but I'll tell you what like
you know you can't really listen to all
the the announcements and patch and uh
what's his name uh Adam schefter and of
course they have valuable knowledge but
it's not over until it's over that's all
I can say about that it's not over we
don't know where obj going until we find
out where obj going
um you know I know they say the Cowboys
and the Giants of this and that and you
just got to wait and see man that's
that's all I'm gonna say about that I
don't want to you know create any
headlines I think it's already a lot of
headlines
um you know we just had to wait and see
you know he said he was going to sign at
the beginning of December uh right in
there so you guys just had to wait and
see I don't want to spill no tea or
nothing like that let him go see the
Cowboys let them go see the Giants
but wait till he sees Bill's Mafia and
what we're doing here in Buffalo man I
think he's going to be blown away
um this week's uh title song
I think last week was
last week was powder
just just normal powder last week's song
was just powder
um in this week's title song would have
to be
uh making music in Motown
making music in Motown for sure or they
want to know about Detroit okay first
and foremost
the Detroit Lions have a tough team and
it's led by Dan Campbell he's an Aggie
too
um this week is going to be a
harnessness
um and we gotta find a way to be the
Hornets in that game
um they got a team for the tough guys I
got a lot of respect for Jamal Williams
a lot of respect for this offensive line
decker and Sewell
um I love Jerry golf he's one of my
favorite quarterbacks he's one of my
favorite quarterbacks out
um this defense is is stacked
um Jeffrey acuta very very Talent very
very talented uh QB I mean uh cornerback
and he's from Dallas one of my boys
um
and uh yeah it's gonna be it's gonna be
a hard for our game just like all of the
games that they've been on and they they
own a three-game win streak and they
beat the um they had they beat the the
New York Giants and they're a really
good team as well so you know you can go
up there and be the Giants man we got we
got to be in our p's and q's
um at Ford Stadium this week man on
Thanksgiving everybody's gonna be
watching man it's gonna be a tough game
I already know man
and um you know this week
playing the Detroit Lions on
Thanksgiving I just want to dedicate
this game
to Bill's Mafia the city of Orchard Park
and the City of Buffalo and Western New
York man for
you know really helping us out a
football team like you guys came out and
and dug us out and did all this extra
stuff and brought out your plowers and
you know just to hear the stories from
some of my teammates like one of my
teammates woke up the next morning he
heard like an engine outside and he
looked outside and it was the neighbors
had all gathered around to like dig them
out like nobody had asked him to do it
or anything like that they just knew
like he played for the Buffalo Bills and
he has to get out because he has to
travel to Detroit
and it just shows you the type of
community that we have and you know how
much they love the game of football here
so
you know if I could give all you guys
game balls like we would we got to
figure a way to do that we're gonna give
everybody their help you know all of all
of my teammates and everybody else
um to get it we're gonna we're gonna
figure a way to get those guys game
balls
um and we're going to dedicate this game
on Thanksgiving
to the city of Orchard Park Buffalo
and Western New York and we're going to
dedicate this game to Bill's Mafia I
really appreciate you guys man for
tuning in to this week's Von Cass I'm
Von Miller
and I'm out